three two one oh
nice did that sound good to anybody else
no
that's not horrible [ __ ] you guys that
was amazing that was like the most in
sync it's ever been
it sounded awful on my own it was so in
sync
the baby bye-bye justin timberlake
what do i look like i don't even know
what i look like you're an old man with
a crossbow
what do you look awesome
oh god bobbers oh
oh you sons of [ __ ] hang on okay
we're not in each other right
no for the first time in a while we're
not inside each other jesus
wade your eyes oh my god why are you
staring so intensely at my crotch wade
i i don't know wait do you wanna wade
um bob you wanna turn around for
no get the camera away
oh no it's broken
there we go all go first
crowbars out i don't know wait a minute
escape the asylum was that literally the
asylum and that's all we needed to
escape
i'm reading i'm getting a psychic
message it's invested in
wade's blood
love your long time i'm not sure what it
means but stand up against that door
no wade yeah stand right there something
here what are you gonna do oh no
no no no no no no stand right there turn
around no i don't want you to look at me
while i do this no
turn around turn around
what's that red light
you douche it's about to explode
is it open yet i don't think so but
there's something on the floor over here
so oh
oh oh oh
okay we didn't break nothing wait how do
i turn i've got no sound in game
why don't you have sound in game oh how
do i turn the sound off i have too much
sound in game oh yeah you probably need
to turn that down
uh maybe that's not like ten percent how
much
how much sound is there in this no no no
ten percent there we go now
could you freaking move
i'm moving move don't make me think that
blood is nothing
okay catch me
you dick i'll catch you is that one will
you catch me
yes i will absolutely okay
hey you both got me [ __ ] oh wait got
you okay you're welcome
i think we need to go that way and break
what the hell
what was that did you see that bob you
dropped out of corpse
what did you get there i swear to god
you crept out of corpse
that's not a good thing no what was that
i possessed
wait i i'm losing control wait wait wait
bob's wait
is this please we're going to do is
we're just going to kill each other over
and over again for no reason yeah okay
you hang on that's not working press the
use button
oh see douches you didn't press the use
button you morons
i didn't know that yeah well you never
played half-life
oh i think someone's pooping out some
grenades over there
there must be a monster can i open it
with my grenades no just try it
your blood is a key i'm sorry wait
that's got to be the last time oh hello
okay so do we need to go through this
door yeah okay i'm going in
pretend that was really scary oh hello
hey way there's someone in that room for
you oh yeah wait you go first yeah wait
how about their friend
i'll follow you with me too i'll follow
as well
yeah yeah go you go first and then
she left she left why can't i go in that
room
maybe i went back in what do you want to
do you can't even go in that other room
hang on let's just move forward get out
of my way
besides the pitch
that's all everybody knows from jeep
mcgowan wade
get out of my way i swear to god
do we shoot doors to open them or no no
no
i don't know see we need is this star
wars rules or
real life i think we need the retinal
scanner so we got to sever this guy's
head somehow
oh i got it that's doing it yeah keep
doing it yeah
i got it i got it should i help yeah
keep doing it okay i'll help
uh i don't know if this is uh this guy's
got a tough hat i don't know
i don't know if that's doing it hang on
i got i got a plan okay i'm getting out
of the room for this plan i think
oh wait wait you ass
all right let's have a truce for a
little bit here yes i'm a truce
we're just tourists ah oh come on
truce
oh god you you you okay i'm good i've
got i'm good you do look like you needed
to be put down for a little bit there
we gotta open this door somehow oh i
opened it
who's leading i opened it i'll go okay
is that cheating why is his wall
it's you oh god wait it was you was it
yeah oh wait are you going to betray us
that way you're here baby whoa hello
okay thanks all right then
well then my frame rate has dropped okay
oh no that's
bad that's bad
okay hey what the hell i don't know hey
there's a dude up there
hey you get down
he's not getting down hang on i got this
we might have to adjudicate him
you douchebag that's about right that
looks good
hey mark why does my frames rate such
ass in this room
looks good get in there
yeah that looks good yeah oh yeah oh
how do i it's pushing me away god damn
it
somebody jump somebody jump push oh it's
looking in there oh you just gotta climb
up
come on okay that makes more sense
you're goddamn idiot what the hell oh
ah
oh here we go this door was up why don't
you guys press your damn use buttons you
would get
through things i thought we came through
that door no we
teleported into this place oh you didn't
remember the tiny door
oh that's right why is it lying upside
down yeah that's just really annoying
with the upside downness
yeah this is oh hang on there's there's
a key here ah i got a key
all right so it's another door yeah whoa
what ah dark oh my god oh dear why ah
guys
who is this i'm here who is that uh
hello hi hi hi uh
hi he's in timeout so you got in trouble
no no no no no no no [ __ ] if you could
get off me for a second yes i know your
name
wait hello you are a beautiful
individual you know that right
yes i've always thought so i've always
thought so too here
let me sit on your face
this wall thank you you now have a ghost
baby
help me wait are you stuck
bye wade you're welcome don't leave me
you're welcome wade i got another key
all right bob now you and me we can go
off adventuring you wait
uh you first bob you're broken
you don't know where we spawn what
i found it by cheating so it's mine okay
you can have the tiger i'll
we'll just finish the game i don't i
don't quite understand why that exists
but i like it this door opens secret
tiger room
oh god yes oh no wait it closed and we
can't come in there oh no
but i got the key wait no
oh no no you'll never be able to get out
no no no no
oh yeah all right fine okay
downright perturbing if you ooh the exit
we're almost free
yeah oh it's another one hooray
hooray the exit hooray oh another one
oh jolly good hey next
let's see this seems misleading no no no
no
oh okay shut down the trash compactor's
on there
okay
just go to the test level okay
started going through puberty the other
day whoa whoa what's behind us
oh oh bob why are you bob
uh what what i hear something
there was something behind us bob you
were like inside some dude's mouth for a
little
dead end oh he's a ladder
congratulations ramp up the ladder all
at once
we have to do some hardcore parkour to
get out of this one we gotta throw
ourselves in the trash actually
sure wait we don't gotta go this way go
this way you douches
morons how do we stop to do that yeah
that was awesome
well worth the fire shots what are you
doing
do not kill me i was shooting at the air
around your head
oh okay whoa what the hell in a small
guy what what the hell
what uh did we do good
i have an idea can you guys see when i
do this
no no oh i was using the camera can we
oh sorry
i didn't think that would work we good
job all around
no like sound effect or screen that says
congratulations you made it anything
like that
with a briefcase and that was it not
that i know you're so good job
everybody yay
i wish this was not
how much i happening